Tulsi gabbard ran for president in 2020
served in the Congress from Hawaii and
of course continues to serve in the US
military Congressman thank you so much
for coming on tonight
um this does seem well not only
something we're going to be deeply
ashamed of in 10 years but also way out
of the scope of the military's Mission
uh completely you know when we look at
what these DOD Physicians are advocating
for it's just the latest of the
taxpayer-funded mandatory woke education
training programs that they now want to
put in place across the entire DOD
Healthcare System and saying that hey if
there are any military members who have
children who come and present themselves
with gender dysphoria symptoms as they
say they're literally in that article
they say that the only Pathway to treat
these children is to immediately uh
prescribe these these hormones these
these abusive hormones and procedures on
these on these children and often
without even notifying the parents that
this is this is going on the the good
news in this is that there are about 50
percent of DOD Affiliated Physicians who
are saying hey look I don't care what
kind of training you give we refuse to
do this we refuse to comply with this
the bad news is there are half of DOD
Affiliated doctors who are just willing
to go along with it well this is what
poses
my beg your pardon
you can use the VA as a veteran right
would you be comfortable getting Medical
Care from someone who believed this I
mean I for me no and I think a lot of
parents in the military my brothers and
sisters uniform would also have very
serious concerns and that's really goes
to uh understanding this is not this is
not a done deal this is not a hopeless
cause we need to take action and make
sure that DOD and Congress does three
very specific things number one
stop this training tell the dod we're
not going to give you a single penny
unless you stop this training from
occurring number two the dod needs to
get rid of these Physicians who are
essentially activists promoting this
ideology within the dod Healthcare
System and number three four you know my
brothers and sisters in uniform in the
military who are very concerned about
your children as well as parents who are
concerned about school health counselors
and others talk to your physician talk
to your pediatrician talk to your school
health counselor make sure they're on
the same page and that they're not one
of these 50 percent who are just willing
to go along this woke agenda that is
being so abusive to our kids so rather
than just I've got a frog in my throat
talking about this is a problem I beg
your pardon but rather than just
complain about it you have three
solutions defund the training yes get
rid of people who were not obviously
emotionally qualified to dispense
Medical Care yes crazy doctor seven
years old Tucker seven years old they're
saying kids are equipped to make this
decision for themselves you to sterilize
themselves for life that's that's insane
definition of and then speak the truth
exactly
Chelsea gabbard I am really grateful
that you're brave enough to say that in
public thanks for having me in this
moment thank you good to see you very
much